[Music]
we heard that thousands of teen girls
auditioned for the role of Andy Mack but
that you're the only one who impressed
the casting agents so we have to ask you
Peyton
what did you do differently than
everyone else we mean you hardly had any
acting credits to your name and you won
everyone's vote in the blink of an eye
that's super impressive and we got to
say we can't imagine a better person
playing Andy Mack than you Peyton you're
the end of your fans deserved something
Andy has to do now got it
the cast of Annie Mac has plenty of
strict rules to follow and many of them
began in the auditioning room keep
watching to find out which of these
rules almost cost
Joshua Rush the role of Cyrus don't wear
makeup
Terry Minsky is the creator of Disney
Channel's Andy Mac and she had a set of
rules she wanted to follow while trying
to cast the lead of her show she wanted
to find the real Andy Mac but that
wasn't exactly easy one role that Terry
lived by while trying to cast Andy's
role was the no makeup role any teenage
girl who walked into the audition room
with a face full of makeup automatically
didn't land the part not that Andy needs
makeup but sometimes it's nice to be
noticed in a different way make the
Disney Channel proud another rule the
cast of Andy Mack lives by is trying to
make the Disney Channel proud since the
Disney Channel employs loads of children
and teenagers they want to make sure
that their actors have a clean slate and
a drama-free past and future being a
kind of person who knows what to say and
what not to say is a very well-known
rule amongst Disney actors scandals can
get actors fired from the Disney family
in no time don't overdress another rule
that terry Minsky lived by while casting
the actors of Andy Mack was to pay close
attention to their clothing anyone who
showed up with her audition her dress
immediately lower their chances of
snagging a role Terry wanted to cast
young teenagers wearing converse not
teenagers and heels and iron curled hair
in other words the Disney Channel wants
its actors to show up to auditions as
themselves and not some overdress zombie
what no tweeting once you've been
welcomed into the ante Mac family there
are some things you need to know one of
them being that tweeting without
permission just isn't an option
working with minors can be tough and
their emotions can get the best of them
so Disney wants to make sure that they
aren't going to spill some
behind-the-scenes secrets on social
media and since the fans of the Annie
Mac show are young kids preteens and
teenagers Disney wants to make sure the
show's afters weren't hosting anything
ahead of their demographic looks like a
kid this might just be the most
important rule of all and Terry Minsky
used it to find her lead actress Peyton
Elizabeth Lee Terry knew what Annie's
style was supposed to look like and she
knew what it wasn't supposed to look
like that's why a dressing like a kid
was an unspoken rule throughout the
audition process Disney wants its actors
to dress like the kids they are not the
adults though one day we come so the
cast of Andy Mack had to maintain a
certain look throughout the entire
series both on and off the camera take
etiquette classes
the last thing Disney want is a scandal
which is why they want their actors to
make them proud but this rule goes
beyond what many people would label as
normal the cast of Andy Mack had to take
etiquette classes to learn how to act in
public excuse me this rule goes beyond
what you post on social media and
focuses on every aspect of its actors
lives the cast had to learn how to speak
prim and proper answer interview
questions
avoid testy situations and everything in
between don't crack any jokes
Andy Mac might be a comedic sitcom but
the show's casting agents didn't want
actors trying to crack any jokes during
their auditions but according to Terry
Minsky many of the kids who auditioned
have been instructed by their acting
coaches to deliver some comedic quips
the Disney Channel enjoys funny actors
but they don't want anyone trying to
tell them how to write their dialogue
they'd much rather have a clean slate to
work with don't break character now this
is a very important role that the cast
of Andy Mack has to live by they can't
break character while out in public
despite being her own person Peyton
Elizabeth Lee is expected to act like
and II every time she runs into a fan or
it gives an interview hoped to be a
strong kind woman just like Leland and
Lauren for my work family and the same
goes for the rest of the cast audition
more than once if you want to be a
Disney Channel star you need to have a
few competitive bones in your body it's
the only way you'll get through the
vigorous auditioning process despite
being the producers top pick to play
Andy Payton had to audition for the role
more time since she could count the
network executives pinned her against
new crops of actors again and again
until they were certain that she was the
one and only Andy Mac one sitcom at a
time a very strict rule every Disney
star has to follow is not overloading
themselves with work this means that
they can only star in one sitcom at a
time
this rule almost cost Joshua Rush the
role of Cyrus because he had already
been hired as the lead for another
Disney pilot Joshua chose to ditch the
pilot to take on the role of Cyrus which
was a smart move considering the pilot
eventually got canceled I was so pumped
I'm so excited
before you go tell us who your favorite
auntie Mac character is and why in the
comments thanks for watching give this
video a big thumbs up and subscribe to
the things so you never miss another
video who will catch you next time
[Music]